round and round the windmill Hut goes
but when did it start no one knows or do
we one of the most famous songs from one
of the most famous instruments in the
Legend of Zelda comes from one of the
most famous games ocarina of time the
song of storms has for many years been
heralded as not only one of the
catchiest Tunes from the entire
franchise but also the one shrouded in
the most mysterious of backstories in
the game link has taught the song as an
adult by this angry little man in a
windmill hunt who claims that a mean kid
from seven years ago played it and it
messed up the windmill fast forward a
bit
or should I say rewind a bit and it's
revealed that the mean kid from seven
years ago was none other then link
himself as a kid who plays the song he
was taught from seven years in the
future teaching the angry man for the
first time in the past the song of
storms when it was none other than the
angry man himself who taught links seven
years later What nonsense is this you
ask well this is referred to as a
bootstrap paradox which is purely
theoretical mind you in other words a
paradox of time travel where a
particular event seems to have created
itself with no discernable origin point
it's like saying which came first the
chicken or the egg can you have an egg
without a chicken laying it or can you
have a chicken without hatching out of
an egg you get what I'm saying but if
these paradoxes like the song of storms
are purely theoretical how could I
possibly claim to have solved it well
I'm glad you asked so by the way before
I delve into the meat of the video if
you like ocarina of time in the you know
ocarina of time from said game you may
enjoy this theory I made recently on the
origins of that legendary instrument in
which case I'll link to it in the
description below and put a card on the
screen right here also to those of you
watching which is you right now make
sure you're subscribed to the channel
I've been looking at my analytics over
the past Oh forever and it looks like
only about 9% of my viewers come from
subscribers mean the vast majority of
you who enjoy my content regularly
aren't actually subscribed so if you've
been enjoying my content so far make
sure you hit that button with the bell
on so that you don't miss out on all the
upcoming goodness
speaking of which be sure to keep an eye
out on your notifications for some
really special stuff coming or real soon
but anyway to start the theory off I am
going to reference what no doubt many of
you who know the games well are already
affecting the sequel to Ocarina of Time
Majora's Mask yes in the direct sequel
to Ocarina of Time there exists a very
peculiar clue that at first glance seems
way too obvious to be true but bear with
me I need to set some things up first so
for those who are unfamiliar Majora's
Mask takes place in the land of termina
which is a land that exists in a
different universe than the Hyrule of
ocarina of time now explaining all of
that would be a different already
thought-out theory entirely so moving
onward with this logic because it is a
different yet parallel universe there
are certain parallels between the two
and one of these parallels is the
counterpart characters present all over
the place in termina you've got the
counterpart citizens counterpart which
is an even counterpart angry dude named
guru-guru but the ones that I'll be
focusing on in this video are the
counterpart composer brothers known as
sharp and flat in ocarina of time the
brothers which I have another really
good theory about in the description
below are revealed to be deceased
musical scientists who served the royal
family by conducting songs with magical
properties such as the song of time or
the son song in Majora's Mask the
brothers are mostly the same except for
the fact that one of them sold their
soul to the devil and is now evil yeah
no joke sharp literally sold his soul to
the devil and imprisoned his brother
flat then proceeded to attempt to suck
the life out of link with a deft song
when they first meet yeah Majora's Mask
is kind of dark but anyway here's where
this story of the brothers ties in
directly to the song of storms when you
meet flat which is the brother that's
imprisoned he teaches you a song that is
meant to heal his brothers curse and can
you guess what this song is yeah none
other than the song of storms now let me
ask you this in a game that already
primarily features healing sorrows with
the song of healing why in the world
would they add in this already
well-known song and distinctly have it
used to heal instead of the song of
healing if you play the song of healing
for sharp he even directly comments on
the music and meeting it's soothing but
not that soothing ultimately having no
effect on him and yet the song of storms
is the one that breaks his curse it's
such a definitive move from the
developers that it's impossible to be
simple convenience right and because
it's such a
distinct addition to the lore of the
Zelda franchise we must consider the
fact that we now have an origin story
for the song so here we have an origin
story but obviously some major pieces
for this theory are still missing I mean
how did the song get back to Hyrule from
termina and then how was it taught to
the angry guy who taught it to Link who
taught it to the angry guy well let's
fast forward to the next game in the
timeline for a clue in Twilight Princess
link the hero of Twilight meets his
ancestor the hero of time who has been
dead now for a while hmm and I also have
a pretty cold theory about him too man I
keep plugging my own videos well you get
to doing this for a while and eventually
you'll start to have theories bleed over
into each other but anyway the hero of
time also known as the dead hero shade
is present with the hero of Twilight in
Hyrule meaning he obviously made it back
to Hyrule as we see at the end of
Majora's Mask and then grew old and died
somehow but the point being he made it
back to Hyrule with the knowledge of the
song of storms so here it is what if the
force that introduced the song to the
bootstrap paradox in the first place was
none other then link himself but not in
the way that you're thinking what if
when link was sent back in time at the
end of the game to before any of the
events transpired before the windmill
hut was messed up from the song of
storms he didn't bother teaching it to
the angry man and headed off on his
majora adventure immediately but when he
eventually returned to Hyrule from
termina as it is heavily implied in
Twilight Princess he remembered that in
order for the future adult timeline
himself to be successful he has to teach
the angry man the song of storms after
all he can't leave the entire adult
timeline hanging so he teaches the song
of storms from termina to the angry
windmill guy which makes the future
adult link timeline able to learn the
song and when adult timeline link goes
back to child timeline link before any
of the events transpired he again
already knows the song and can teach it
to the angry man once more that was a
very long sentence now I know what you
think dude
Masamune betta isn't that still
cycle and yes yes it is and it always
will be as we see playing the game in
ocarina of time but if you're thinking
of a cycle like the circular letter O
think of this as a capital letter Q it's
still a cycle round and round it goes
but we now know where the song came from
well maybe this all just makes sense in
my head now granted this isn't the only
theory about the origins of the song
another theory actually ties in with one
of Nintendo black crisises theories he
did on the inevitable timeline meaning
there are certain things and events
destined to happen by the hands of fate
itself that will happen no matter what
the song of storms could be one of these
things that simply came to be by the
hand of destiny kind of like a link
being born every time stuff gets real
bad but that sounded a little too easy
to me but what did you think with the
song of storms conducted by flat who
literally is said to have conducted the
song in Majora's Mask or did it simply
come to be by the will of fate itself
let me know in the comments below
hey guys thank you so much for watching
once again be sure to LIKE and subscribe
if you haven't already whipped that Bell
icon to stick around for all the juicy
good stuffs to come and trust me there's
gonna be a lot as always huge thanks to
my amazing patrons including three count
them three new editions Robley Bob
leaves sorry if I butchered that germ
and zani Anderson you guys seriously
make my day every day and I can't thank
you enough for that if you are
interested in getting your name up here
and access to some exclusive content
that will be coming soon check out the
links in the description below also down
there are links to my social media sites
like Twitter and discord server so
connect with me there too if you want to
that's all I've got for you this time I
hope you have a great rest of your day
this is Masum panda bandit signing out
through
[Music]